Grammy nominations came out today yeah
thank you yeah oh yeah I cleaned up
no Grammy nominations came out guess
what Bernie Sanders has been nominated
for a Grammy Award for Best audiobook of
course of course Bernie's supporters are
already complaining that the Grammys are
rigged so that Hillary will win that's
what they're saying
yeah pretty bitter about they're still
better yeah better
Prince Harry getting married that's
exciting news genealogy experts say that
Prince Harry and his fiancee Meghan
Markel are actually distant cousins
mm-hmm yeah after hearing they were
related Queen Elizabeth finally gave the
couple her blessing do things over there
yeah keep that bloodline tight yeah yeah
yeah of course people are mad probably
heard about this people are mad at
President Trump for meeting with Native
American leaders in front of a portrait
of anti Native American President Andrew
Jackson yeah even worse today President
Trump met with Hispanic leaders in front
of a portrait of President Trump
that's crazy he's gonna have a portrait
in the White House yeah he sure is
I'm particularly looking forward to the
Hall of Presidents at Disneyland yeah I
forgot about that he's good and up and
yeah yeah all right I want to get into
it's Tuesday here I was thinking of all
kinds of stuff and I gonna let it go
speaking of Trump this week Secretary of
State Rex Tillerson said that Russia
isn't acting like a responsible nation
yeah yeah present Trump agreed saying
they haven't paid me in months they are
way behind I'm owed money big money
nicely done Tony yeah I like when I get
your this is a good session of
Parliament big news in the fast food a
world Arby's has acquired Buffalo Wild
Wings for 2.4 billion dollars yeah
yeah they didn't they didn't mean to but
like a lot of us Harvey's got drunk and
bought too many wings so this guy said
that joke wouldn't work
like that's not gonna work and I'm like
and I will try it we'll see what happens
audience
a tumbleweed blew through the crowd when
that joke went out yeah what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do it's the
volume business sure is we move a lot of
joke merchandise he can't get all
worried about one joke that's right
he's wrong sometimes - here we go MTV
MTV announced it's bringing back the
original cast of Jersey Shore can you
believe it every single cast member was
available in Indiana a high school
teacher was caught in her classroom
snorting cocaine yeah people became
suspicious when parent-teacher
conferences lasted only ten seconds
[Applause]
they cycle them through pretty well huh
I'd be great
you